Was my first TikTok
buzz. Act out.
I'm spits in Canada,
lead candidate for the European Greens.
My name is Terry Radke.
I'm now the leading candidate for the European Greens.
For the European elections in 2024.
I think the injustice that I saw in the world.
I was very engaged in protest against the Iraq war,
and then I became a very convinced feminist.
And obviously, the struggle for energy transition,
the core of Europe, why we have Europe.
We've. We've lost that idea,
that peace project, and Europe to be proud of.
I think we should bring that back.
There is a lot to do.
Obviously, we have the continuation of the Green Deal.
Fight for strong climate policy,
fighting for social justice,
but also defending democracy,
rule of law, and fundamental rights.
No, not really.
Climb a deal in Paris. That was a great moment.
I would tell them to go to Greece or to go to Spain,
where people have lost their livelihoods
because of climate change.
Really. That the companies are going to finally
pay their taxes.
Blocking a Nazi demonstration.
Fight the hypocrites of the conservatives.
A fictional character would be Princess Leia,
leading the Rebel Alliance. But, I mean,
the non fictional character that I love to run with,
obviously sparse.
Please go out and vote.
We need you, and the climate needs you.
Don't take democracy for granted.
Go again and vote.
And. But also maybe rethink the choices that you have.
Made in the past.
Maybe first biking,
doing some mountains, and then a concert.
I love running. I love being in the forest.
I really like cleaning.
Choose carriage.
This was my first TikTok